la fin des blocages ferroviaire permet
au cn de rappeler au travail la plupart
des employés mis à pied dans l'est du
canada
la mesure a touché 450 travailleurs du
cn à montréal lévis moncton et près
d'halifax
plus de 1400 train de marchandises ou de
voyageurs ont été retardés ou annulés
durant les dernières semaines la
barricade à kahnawake n'a pas d'effet
sur le cn mais empêche le fonctionnement
du train de banlieue les trains de via
rail toronto ottawa montréal ont repris
partiellement pour la première fois
depuis quatre semaines
nous avons rencontré le pdg du cn cet
après midi monsieur ruelle bonjour
bonjour comment ça se passe en ce moment
on a parlé du rappel des employés qui
commence à se faire est-ce que vous à
quel pourcentage de reprise d'activité
vous êtes rendu présent notre retour
d'opération s'est fait en quelques
étapes la première étape c'est l'ouest
canadien vous souvenez que le dernier
bloqué c'était vraiment autour de
belleville on a commencé à mettre dans
nos opérations notre la côte ouest
toronto
ensuite à partir du moment où les blocus
de belleville est élevée on a commencé à
gagner aux choses à leur ordre entre
belleville et halifax
puisque les employés ont recommencé en a
rempli en rappelez sûrement placé
vendredi passé on avait 450 aux
canadiens et aux mars par la majorité de
ces gens là ont été rappelés par tous
mais la majorité est ce que tous seront
rappelés éventuellement oui j'espère
qu'on pourra les appeler à la fin de
cette semaine
ce qu'il nous faut ce moment et cesser
d'être un qui viennent de l'ouest
vancouver puisque vers montréal et les
maritimes se sont finalement qui aiment
le travail au quai des trains qui
viennent principalement des parts de
l'ouest
ensuite est-ce qui s qui viennent de
l'ouest les truites qui m'ont repris à
100 % leur agressivité assez durement
les une période où on utilise toutes nos
ressources
on a enlevé hier ce qu'on appelle un
embargo sur les chemins de fer
américains pour le produit qui sont
finalistes canada donc on opère au
maximum qu'on peut opérer quand même un
train de l'ouest canadien à montréal ça
prend quand même cinq six jours dans le
temps que le petit le produit arrive le
temps que ça crée du travail
et puis les jeux dans l'ouest canadien
au port de vancouver ou par la presse ou
par on n'allait pas et du corps où la
balle c'est à dire que déjà cette
semaine c'est vrai les entrées de
containers sont déjà à la baille si
parlement qu' on a déjà trois terminal
sur la côte ouest sur cinq qui a
pratiquement plus de contenu n'importe
importations à faire entrer dans les
temps donc le corps un virus affecte
aussi vos absences par will on est rendu
à ce point il a donc maintenant je pense
que le post ce blocus sort on a du coup
c'est le client mail très cher aux
migrants de revenus combien si vous avez
une évaluation oui je qualifierais ou
marron sur turin nous résultons mot
d'ordre et les pouvoirs de grandeur si
pour le mandat même ordre de grandeur
que l'arrêt de travail qu'on avait au
moment de la banque donc c'est quand
même beaucoup de pertes de revenus des
coûts d'opération et aussi une
productivité qui est à la baisse parce
que on a eu 34 voix que certains qui ont
duré ce mickael casar dont on dirait
plusieurs jours donc c'était difficile
pour nous d'avoir un plan l'opération
cohésif sans savoir d'avoir souhaité
après les obstructions comment vous avez
géré les blocus parce qu'on est vous le
dit des images que je pense qu'on vient
dé voir où on va les revoir là des
images quand même assez difficile
notamment la reprise avec ce train qui
avançait alors qu'il y avait des gens
sur la voie volery comment vous avez
géré ce soir c'est vers la fin donc on
dirait vraiment au jour le jour savoir
quelles informations qui nous venaient à
mesure qu'il venait où étaient les
blocus qu'est ce qu'on faisait au point
de vue injonctions ou avec les autres et
civile pour demander aux gens de dicter
d'olive beaulieu et vous prévu
l'opération qu'est ce que ça implique
une nouvelle opération pour les trains
crois qu'il avait pu opérer que ce saint
pierre sur tout nouveau les clients je
pense les gens passent beaucoup c'est un
mais c'est plus important que le cn
s'est pourtant produit un peu plus car
majorité des clients qui n'utilisent
aucun site grêlé mais une fois que tu
sois fort et si l'énergie les grandes
villes qui ont soit des containers donc
un peu en opération qui était sujet le
repérer et puis quand on parle de les
dernières choses que vous parlez à
belleville c'est quand même des choses
dangereuses qu'elles échangent re
dangereux c'est mélanger des trains avec
des gens vrais c pa 17 une opération
industrielle ou au tout les gens qui
sont avérés des opérations industrielles
voit des gens qui travaillent là puis
connaissent la syrie
vous aviez
au moment du passage du tram jeu juste
m'arrêter sur ces images là parce
qu'elle est quand même important oui
vous aviez au passage du train une
injonction pour passer de plus depuis
déjà beaucoup et pas exactement
oui les manifestants dont ils n'avaient
pas de faire là mais ce qu'un train doit
quand même avancer s'il ya des gens qui
sont sur la voie ferrée or nous en
suivre ce soit sur exactement sur le
site web des protestataires sur le site
a eu donc on arrive j'ai vu moi-même les
deux heures excentive se sont passées
avec les gens n'étaient pas sur la
traque les gens étaient sur le
territoire et quand le train avance et
c'est là qu'ils ont décidé par décider
plus ou moins d'affronter le train alors
je pensais plutôt à ça cela veut juste
qu'on le voit oui je sois je veux juste
m'arrêter là-dessus dans les gens sont
là comment par personne
je savoure l'instant
alors les gens sont là oui le train s'en
vient qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment
là pourquoi le train continue
les gens sont là le train les gens
n'étaient pas sur la traque quand les
treize années je crois y avait aussi la
police provinciale qui était le côté de
la track
la police nous a dit que le train s'en
venaient les gens ont décidé de se
mettre en direction du train d'affronter
le train le train voyez les vitesses
l'épeautre actuellement vides ils ont le
compte de l'équipe du site a fait ce
qu'il devait faire les avertit concerne
la turballe avec contact visuel ce que
nous avait ralenti ou freiner à ce
moment là je peux pas vous dire mais il
ya les invités est telle que les gens
aient définitivement le choix de pro
faire ce qu'ils ont fait et de façon
évidente ils ont personne peut gagner
face à un train de milieu donc je pense
la logique était pas d'heure mais est ce
que ça vous trouble quand même si ce
match là oui ça me trouble que qu'on est
rendu au point d'en sociétés ou des
choses des règles de sécurité et aussi
importante que ce soit que les gens
décident de les mettre de côté un train
c'est pas une bicyclette s'arrête pas
sur indices ou et puis on parle de
risque important est ce que tout ça
affecte vos affaires affecte l'image
qu'à l'international où affecte la
perception qu'on peut avoir de faire des
affaires au canada et d'investir aucun
bruit ça fait que ça affecte nos gens
puisque nous envoyer les gens qui
s'occupent par exemple qui était à une
situation comme ça c'est pas des choses
qui qui veut faire le matin car qui
débutent leur quart de travail points de
vie la réputation du canada
c'est vraiment rien de positif moi j'ai
book clients qui sont en asie et en
europe les gens avec qui on fait faire
beaucoup d'heures on avait une
conférence à fait fonctionnel pas assez
à l'ongle et y étaient rationnés quand
c'est la cause que renault va rythmer la
réputation canadienne et brazi ce que
c'est les gens voient à l'extérieur et
le traitement ils ont pas une bille
diffusera tous les détails
et puis aussi je pense que en affaires
les gens font les choses qui sont les
plus impossibles
donc ça devient trop compliqué de faire
affaire au canada pour cela deux raisons
les chaînes d'approvisionnement mon cher
chez les bises les délais par les
activités qui sont plus simples faciles
plus fiables
quelle est la suite après tous ces
événements
elie la suite pour le canadien national
partir donc la suite maintenant c'est
aider nos clients à regagner leur port
de marché donc prudemment le secteur qui
sont ici ont le plus de retard c'est
également la russie forestière et
d'industrie du grand vancouver il ya un
train sous performant et environ 50 55
bateaux qui sont en attente de greffe
normalement talent environ 30 l'on
connaît on y environ à 10000 wagon de
retard sur la côte ouest
et puis la russie forestière eux dans le
certains cas ils ont perdu l'avant donc
site pour peut exécuter la vente durant
le mois de février parlement que
quelqu'un d'autre a rempli la rentrée
producteur américain oprah sur deux est
ce que vous allez donner priorité je
pense au propane ou denrées périssables
par exemple le propane s'est ainsi
chiffré qui était beaucoup d'envié dans
l'immédiat on a donné priorité ils ont
tout le blocus au propane ou temps qu'on
pouvait le faire
je pense que les gens samena aussi qu'on
a réussi à passer certains trains par le
lord ontario ou alors certains trains
par le 6è sexe par les états unis ou par
part of law toronto et retour à montréal
et vers la fin du blocus quelques temps
dit-on par asus le canadien pacifique
des deux villes qui est toujours une
quantité de propane qui circulait vers
le québec on a toujours faire l'effort
outre la plus de 4 le plus de capacité
qu'on avait essayé de gérer ça de cette
façon qu'on pouvait amener une certaine
classe et d'approvisionnement je serais
surpris qu'il ya une pénurie de propane
au québec très bien monsieur roux et
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci pour
cet entretien jacent